hi everyone my name's Tamra chambers and
this is Tamra just saw and I just went
and saw John wick 3 the movie where the
Hobbs and shot railer got a standing
ovation this film franchise obviously
has a very large and dedicated following
the sodas counter Eve's just check out
his reddit I love John wick 1 & 2 I
think 2 is just as good as one and I
will say that 3 is just as good as 1 & 2
so exciting so well done just
masterfully executed incredible I don't
know if it's just because it was the
first night or if there was just a big
group of friends who went to my specific
showing but the amount of applause
breaks that we got during this film was
astounding everything got an applause
every single thing lines action
sequences specific scenes just a gun
will show up and just go crazy it was so
freaking fun this movie right out of the
gate is so incredibly exciting the
choreography is unmatched in big-budget
action films today usually in a
big-budget action film that you see
today you get some really cool choreo
some really great action sequences but
in this film and this franchise it's
just non-stop it's just throughout the
entire film non-stop incredible
sequences I remember hearing somewhere
probably on the internet that one of the
sequences in Kill Bill took like two
months to film I don't know if that's
true or not or accurate it's the
internet so definitely is but I just
have to wonder how long each of these
action sequences took to film is there
so specifically Cory ode and it's so
cleanly done and you see everything
that's happening even though it's
absolute pandemonium and it's visually
incredible to look at but technically
like just knowing a the smallest amount
about stage combat it's just
unbelievable what they're doing
he sequences as the second one was this
one takes place directly after the
second and you go straight into it the
first kill was absolutely incredible the
story of this one takes some turns that
I wasn't sure about I didn't know what
the story of this one really was was
going to be where they were taking us on
this wonderful tapestry of a film Doug
Walker saw an early screening of it and
said something similar but there's
there's a point in the middle that's
just kind of like what the hell what are
you what is happening and it all makes
so much sense it's it's so well written
I think Keanu Reeves says under two
hundred words and the entire thing and
his acting is phenomenal I'm such a huge
fan of his I think it was either the
first or second episode of Tamra jests I
saw John wick too and I just decided to
see John wick the first one because I
hadn't for Tamara's never seen and just
fell in love just completely was blown
away a dedication he takes to this part
it's it's crazy you see all these
training videos he's doing in between
these films and he he's so in it so
dedicated and also I mean he's just like
the coolest guy from what you know he
shows to the world what I'm trying to
say is I love you John Reese there's
also some incredible comedy in this
movie it's not jam-packed they're not
like jamming in jokes by any means but
because it's such a serious situation at
all points in time in this film it's it
leads to comedy you know that's what it
is right if you're doing something show
seriously then whatever you're doing is
hilarious so there's some really lovely
moments of super genuine comedy that
feels incredibly fit in it does not feel
at all forced and I think that's another
thing in action big-budget action films
now is like there's always a ton of
comedy which I love I love comedy
interspersed in my action said this in
this week stammers never seen I also
love love intersperse
my my action films but this this was so
such a level above anything that's been
coming out recently in my opinion I
tweeted that John wick is the best
action franchise ever I should have put
in my opinion because people are
disagreeing I oughta think that it
excites me more than any other action
franchise it's it's the most incredible
action franchise oh god I love it
I wrote a gun assemble scene knife scene
horse scene Continental scene underwater
scene that horse scene though we had
that leaked picture like a month or two
back him on a horse shooting someone
who's just really really pumped me up
for this film and we commit to that and
everyone's just screaming their heads
off it was so much fun and it was
amazing it was so so so good in this
film he's a little bit more worn down
than he was in the first two and he just
still brings it just just incredible
there's still some really good dog
content in this
I think the first line of business in
the very beginning of the film is making
sure that his dog is safe without giving
too much away there's another scene also
where a different dog is put in some
danger and I was so the the
killcount at this point in the movie was
so high already but I was in shock about
it anything with dogs it just feels so
much more real for some reason than
human the end is as abrupt and
infuriatingly incredible as the other
two I read an article about John wick
recently I just loved him where the
director or the writer somebody said
that they could continue making these
forever like they could just continue
the world they've built is so
interesting and so cool and the rules
make sense of things and you can just
continue to grow off of it
there's a lot happening outside of my
house tonight H it seems that Keanu
Reeves really loves doing these as well
and I will continue to see them as often
as they are put out I'm gonna wake up
tomorrow and after editing this watch 1
& 2 again it just it was so good so
exciting incredibly executed it looked
beautiful drink water too fast I totally
recommend this movie I'm gonna give this
ten out of ten oh my gosh ripped out my
earring Barry John wicked me okay thank
you so much for watching I'm pretty sure
I'm seeing either Godzilla or Aladdin
next week
that's a interesting what is happening
interesting kind of comparison of movies
there thank you for watching I'll see
you all next week with hopefully a
quieter set bye
are you pissed off yeah
[Music]
you